this page isn't available if you try to
checkout Justin Bieber's Instagram
that's the message you'll be greeted
with what do you mean late last night
after Justin posts this pic with the new
furry friend the sixth most fall of
Instagram users suddenly deletes his
account and there's no doubt it's
related to yesterday's digital drama
with Selena Gomez the former 8th couple
got into an epic online shouting match
where they both accused each other of
being unfaithful during their
relationship and it all started with
Selena commented on one of six selfies
Justin posted with his rumored new
girlfriend Sofia Richie after the
pitchers got some negative reaction
online from fans
Justin captioned the final photo saying
I'm going to make my Instagram private
if you guys don't stop the hate but
Justin takes his threat to the next
level wiping out his account entirely
the star social media shutdown is the
latest job at believers after he
canceled all his upcoming meet and
greets back in March and vowed to never
take fan photos again while Justin shows
no mercy
Selena waives a white flag posting this
message on her snapchat account what I
said was selfish and pointless but
there's no doubt Bieber's behavior still
has her blood boiling
he did after all make the accusation
that Selena was using him to get famous
but today a source tells people calm
that she has never used him adding he
put their relationship out there way
more than she did and he's been very
strategic about it
whenever something good is happening in
her life we'll post something to get at
her and Selena isn't the only
ex-girlfriend that's been jaded by
Justin yesterday before the start
deactivated his account he unfollowed
former flame Haley Baldwin reportedly
because Sophia Ricci made him do it
and Haley is reportedly not happy about
it
shortly afterwards she returns the favor
to Justin by unfollowing him back all
this drama makes me wanna quit answer
got myself does it have listened maybe
just maybe Justin does have the right
idea now we're going to throw it over to
our et Canada's web team we're digital
expert Katt Williams has been monitoring
the entire situation very closely again
thanks guys we are still waiting here to
see if Justin will reactivate his
account but so far nothing there is
however a new rebooted account called
Justin Bieber reboot that has been
verified as real by Instagram but it's
still unclear whether or not this is
Justin's actual account or if it's a fan
now if he doesn't come back some of her
followers on you to Canada's Facebook
can understand why Shannon says don't
blame him people can be very ignorant
today's world while John says he'll be
back lol if he does come back this would
be very much in the style of Demi Lovato
who took a break from Twitter because of
online trolls although it only lasted 24
hours Rihanna on the other hand quit
Instagram for a solid six months because
of the site's censorship rules and then
there stars like Jamie Dornan who quit
social media just after 50 shades of
grey came out alright no doubt it's
complicated navigated a social media
world and celebrities like Madonna are
sounding off on the problem social media
is causing four stars in Hollywood in a
new interview with love magazine Madonna
says I was already famous before social
media so for me Fame isn't the burden
the diva talks about how the younger
generation is depending on social media
as a way to seek recognition and why
that could be detriment
to their careers now it's easy to become
famous
what isn't easy is to develop and grow
as an artist without being distracted or
consumed with Fame and with all this
drama between Justin and Selena online
maybe the Queen of Pop can pass on a few
tips tanner Donna she does have many
more years of wisdom after all and today
she celebrates her 58th birthday happy
birthday I just wanna go